in the lobby of the headquarters of
Ramsey solutions Seth and his wife Patty
is not she didn't make us he couldn't
make it no I'm not here she's got a sick
one at home I hear that she had to watch
after so who's filling in for what's his
young lady's name this is Lily and she
is filling in for her mama who is home
with her brother who is sick and her
younger brother who's two and he he
didn't make the trip either but lots and
lots of people there to take care of so
well we'll let Lily scream on behalf of
Patti so how much debt have you guys
paid off we paid off a hundred and
thirty four thousand total and a little
over three years way to go all right
making what kind of money during that
time started at about seventy and ended
up a little over eighty-five okay so we
we got a house sold uh-huh okay that we
had rented out and we moved out of
rented out we did all made all these
decisions before we met you and we we've
four after four years we finally got got
the house going and rented it out and
had to pay rent and mortgage for a while
but gotcha so how much of the hundred
and thirty-four thousand was the rental
uh ninety okay all right what was the
rest of it the rest of it was credit
cards student loans a car payment and
you guys were normal we were normal I
mean you moved out of a rental bought a
house without having the other one sold
turned it into a rental by default
probably then you had all the normal
debt other than that everything you
bought you bought on debt yes sir and
then you look up so what happened three
years ago what turned the corner for you
I tell me your story on this journey
well we we moved out of that house and
three or in 2011 then for me to go to
grad school I started grad school and
then we look down after we are paying
rent and paying a little bit of mortgage
and we say this is not adding up each
month and somebody at church have been
telling us to go to to go to financial
peace and so we did and we did that
first budget and we were like we got to
do something so I got a I got a
part-time job working at a grocery store
and I was going to school teaching
during the day both my wife and our
teachers and then either going to class
or working at the store at night and I
did that for two and a half years Wow
and we did not have much of a life for a
while and I think we counted up the
longest string of days I worked was 36
straight days of either school teaching
or selling groceries and it was a lot of
work and I didn't do all the work my
wife who was taking care of they were
then
5 and 3 at the time she she did all the
work she was the yeah I think he both
been working their butts off as what
sounds like to me
my 89 year old granddad says he's T
cheaper that tougher than a cheap steaks
that's good
well you guys have held on and gritted
your teeth and pushed your way all the
way through this was it worth it oh
definitely
we had we not done financial piece I
don't know where we would have been we
about halfway through we had to put in a
$5,000 air conditioner in the house we
owned Lou and then we get a call or not
a call but petit goes to the doctor one
day comes home and guess what kids are
gonna be parents again and we paid for
their conditioner cash we paid for the
baby cash we were all we were prepared
everything was done everything was good
and you got all this debt paid off and
got the rental sold all in three years
and we did and now we have our three or
six months emergency fund already built
up Wow so I know moving on the step for
now you probably will never see the
inside of a grocery store the same no
and that's what I enjoyed it I'm
thankful for my time there and I'm glad
that uh that God put me somewhere where
I could provide for my family and and
make ends meet and it it all worked out
very cool but you don't have to go there
now except to buy groceries up to buy
groceries I missed my 10% discount we
don't get that anymore it's been it's
been great that's fun
well congratulations so what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt
for you and Patty or when you paid off a
hundred and thirty four thousand and
three years um I would have to say don't
be afraid to sacrifice and that's that's
what we had to do and and
be content with where you are we rented
the first place we rented once we moved
was very small and we had two kids and a
small in a small bedroom and we were in
the bed it was a two-bedroom one-bath
and then we we've upgraded since then to
an extra bedroom since we've had the
third but don't be afraid to sacrifice
and learn to be content I was thinking
about this on the on the drive over and
I used to coach football and one of the
things we used to
we'd have Bible studies with the players
and one of the things we used to tell
them was I'll read the book of
Philippians Paul wrote the book of
Philippians from a jail cell and he
talks about rejoicing and being joyful
and being content in everything and and
it took me a while to learn that but I
think learning that and learning how to
be content with what you have and living
simply is a great thing but the peace
that passes understanding
4:7 yes sir very cool I love it well
congratulations sir
very well done and long trip where did
you drive from Greenville so about five
hours okay you and Lily had some
daddy-daughter time I did we did we
watch Sound of Music and Mary Poppins so
we'll watch them again on the way back
I'm sure that's how we used to measure
trips when ours were that age huh how
many how many Little Mermaid's does it
take us to get there right that's uh
that's it oh wow well congratulations
guys
very well done our salute goes out to
Patti home with the sick babies and
watching everybody as she does as we do
this but uh so Seth Patti and Lily Lily
filling in for Patti I'm gonna do a debt
free scream a hundred and thirty four
thousand dollars paid off in three years
making seventy thousand two eighty-five
thousand a year count it down alright
let's do a debt free scream ready three
two one we're dead
well done sir very very very well done